et pour en parler nous sommes avec
etienne combier rédacteur en chef de
novastar un média spécialisé sur l'asie
centrale
étienne combier merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors cette
démission du président à ce qu'elle peut
mettre fin au chaos politique
il n'avait plus le choix finalement
bonsoir merci de nous recevoir
a priori je ne pense pas que cette
démission va mettre fin au chaos
on est sûrs comme une émission assez
surprenante même de la part des plus
proches soutiens de ce régime bykov je
pense notamment à felix koulov qui est
un homme politique proche de ceux rubens
bykov qui a aujourd'hui déclaré don qui
a vu sur un match et make-up juste avant
qu'il ne démissionne et il y avait
pourtant assuré qu'il ne démissionnerait
pas donc c'est une démission qui est
intervenue dans des conditions un peu
particulières on sait que sort une
belgique bykov a rencontré donc c'est à
dire japa rohff qui est donc le premier
ministre et président maintenant par
intérim ainsi qu'un autre homme
politique et c'est à la suite de ces
discussions là qu'il a décidé de
démissionner donc on est vraiment sûr
sur une sur une méthode et une manière
qui est particulière voire complètement
flou donc on ne peut pas vraiment dire
que c'est la fin du chaos là en
l'occurrence avec c'est à dire la part
of qui à la fois premier ministre et
président par intérim
il concentre l'ensemble du pouvoir
exécutif entre ses mains et donc on a on
aboutit à une situation assez assez
délicate où on peut c'est compliqué de
d'élaborer une les simplement de savoir
ce qui va se passer dans les prochains
jours alors à chaos politique mais aussi
des manifestations dues aux élections
législatives controversées du 4 octobre
dernier des élections entachées d'achat
de voix et d'irrégularités selon
l'opposition
pourquoi ne fallait il pas attendre de
nouvelles élections législatives alors
ça aurait été effectivement l'idéal le
simple le problème c'est que les partis
d'opposition eux mêmes n'ont pas réussi
à s'accorder du fait de leur leur
désaccord au fait de ces partis ne sont
pas spécialement constituée depuis des
années donc sont constitués uniquement
où précisément pour cette élection donc
ça a été compliqué d'élaborer un
programme ou en tout cas une ligne
commune
ensuite il ya eu effectivement
l'émergence et l'ascension comme vous
l'avez bien décrits dans le sujet de
c'est-à-dire ja par off qui passe de
détenus à chef de gouvernement en cinq
jours c'est absolument incroyable donc
c'est finalement c'est je pense que le
dans l'idéal ça ressemble à du méco fort
et espérer avoir une opposition claire
avec qui discuter pour organiser de
nouvelles élections qui puisse être
justement plus libres ou en tout cas
plus transparente par rapport à celles
qui ont eu lieu le 4 octobre dernier
mais cela n'a pas été le cas du fait de
cette ascension de sa vierge a part of
qui a tout de suite c'est comme vous
l'avez bien mentionné de demander sa
démission et finalement engagé une
épreuve de force avec l'ex-président
kirghiz alors intéressant nous justement
à cet homme qui a profité du chaos c'est
à dire japa rohff
il a été vidé à la semaine dernière vous
le rappeliez pour un premier ministre
qui revendique aujourd'hui la fonction
présidentielle quelle légitimité il a
est ce qu'il est a mal à la manoeuvre
depuis le début alors ça je ne pourrai
pas exactement vous répondre sur la
manoeuvre depuis les bus en l'occurrence
au servage et imité par contre les assez
contestable la seule la première sa
première nomination donc le 10 octobre a
été très critiqué du fait qu'il eut que
50 députés présents pour sa nomination
alors qu'il ya 120 députés au jeu dans
nos jeux korkuc neiges qui est le nom du
parlement kirghiz
il ya une deuxième nomination qui avait
eu lieu donc hier et qui a effectivement
entériné sa sombre son poste de premier
ministre
là où c'est effectivement aussi
compliqué pour sa légitimité c'est que
aujourd'hui en fait pourquoi il se
proclame président par intérim c'est que
dans l'ordre constitutionnel après la
démission de ce rebelle bykov
le président du parlement canadien bec
issaïev aurait dû devenir président par
intérim mais dans l'après midi
enfin dans l'après midi en france mais
dans la soirée au kirghizstan il a déjà
refusé en fait de prendre de prendre ses
fonctions et donc la personne
ensuite qui est donc et
prévue par la constitution c'est le
premier ministre donc c'est à dire la
part of qui a lui-même annoncé sa
aujourd'hui alors même que il grille
finalement la priorité au parlement
kirghiz qui doit se réunir demain pour
examiner la démission du président donc
en fait tout va très très vite et donc
c'est un peu compliqué de trouver
légitimité on a plutôt de la sensation
qui veut à tout prix s'assurer les la
mainmise sur le pouvoir exécutif
plutôt que d'attendre que le parlement
fasse son travail et le nomme
effectivement président par intérim
justement si cela se confirme qu'est ce
qu'on peut attendre d'un éventuel mandat
de cette figure nationaliste alors déjà
il va falloir avoir de nouvelles
élections tout cas déjà parlementaire
puis présidentielle la constitution
impose que après la démission d'un
premier d'un président d'élection
présidentielle ait lieu dans les trois
mois donc aussi sur la constitution le
président par intérim ne peut pas être
candidat aux présidentielles
donc soit c'est-à-dire caparof modifie
la constitution en un temps record c'est
d'ailleurs ce que suggère une des
personnes interviewées dans votre sujet
qui parle de référendum soit ce n'est
pas lui qui va représenter qui doit
devenir président et ce sera quelqu'un
d'autre de son entourage qui va le
devenir
là en l'occurrence c'est un peu c'est un
peu particulier
on sait que en asie centrale en
ouzbékistan notamment à la mort d'islam
karimov en 2016 il ya déjà eu ce cas de
figure où chaque quatre murs a été à la
fois chef du gouvernement et président
par intérim
ça s'est soldé en ouzbékistan par sa son
élection au poste de président mais la
constitution est différente au
kirghizstan et donc on sait pas
exactement c'est un peu tout le tout
l'enjeu c'est à savoir qui comment va
vraiment réagir c'est à dire la période
qu'elles sont ce qu'ils allaient son
programme quand est ce que seront
organisées les élections législatives et
l'élection présidentielle s'il ya quand
même beaucoup de questions ce soir et on
suivra ça de près merci à vous etienne
combier je rappelle que vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de
nova ce temps c'est un média spécialisé
sur l'asie centrale